I am transitioning to a new project
management role yep company okay how do
you maintain having high standards with
your team making sure things get done
but still keeping the project on time
and on budget you know I think it takes
humanity I think the answer is humanity
I actually think the best way to be a
great project manager or get things done
is to be a great listener
instead of talker right you go into this
new role I see with a lot of my project
management people they're organized
they're good but they want to talk it to
success I actually think it's the drop
down flip it and reverse it I think it's
a Missy Elliott structure I think the
way you win is by listening to the
people up to why they're not doing well
why are they two weeks behind if you
haven't actually apply empathy and
understand what's going on there you
become known to everybody as the project
manager that gets it and so I say you
walk in with not your architecture and
organization and like I'm gonna guide
this you're gonna guide it with your
ears more than your mouth and that is
something most project management
oriented people only learn later in life
and realize is the key factor